um on this album you have um Is It
Michael Snead yeah Michael Snead he's on
a lot of Records uh at first I thought
it was you just trying to sing yeah I
was like is this like his AKA no no
Michael sneez he's our side of Oakland
super talented
um yeah I think it's up and coming I
think I think he's got an except too you
know I'm saying he's super dope and just
like the chemistry chemistry we have
um
we like every time we would just get in
the studio we'd write some like some
crazy shoes some crazy [ __ ] right and um
and that's ended up what happened and
like I went up to the Bay for like two
weeks or like a week or two and he was
just like pulling up to the studio and
you know
um whether it was like him on a hook or
whether he was like in there vibing like
we would just always come up with
something super dope super unique and um
yeah I think he's super raw he's super
dope yeah I mean he he's got a crazy
voice that's for sure yeah no very
unique very unique you know and that's I
think that's what the bay brings we we
bring something unique every time